ايضا هناك كاميرات حراريه ايضا هناك
الكلاب المتدربه هاي الان يطلبون الكلب
فاطمه باسل
يطلبون منا الصمت الان نطلبون منا الصمت
وسنحترم ذلك بتاكيد غسان نحن معك نتابع
هذه الصور المباشره عبر كاميرا العربيه في
قهرمان مرعش حيث يتم عمليه انقاذ وانتشار
لطفله تبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات عالقه تحت
الانقاض وتم قبل دقائق قليله انتشال
اختيها على ما يبدو تسع سنوات واحد 11 سنه
وتم نقلهم بالاسعاف وكان معهم خالهم في
الاسعاف وكان يبدو عليه مشاعر السرور
ودموع السرور والفرح لاخراج الفتاتين
وبانتظار اخراج ايضا اختهم البالغه من
العمر سبع سنوات على ما يبدو الان هم في
لحظه صمت ليتمكنوا من سمع اي صوت يصدر من
تحت الانقاض ونحن نتابع معكم لحظه بلحظه
هذه العمليه التي تتم في جنوب تركيا وهي
كما يذكر مفيدنا
مراسلينا عبر تركيا وسوريا عمليات انقاذ
مستمره في المناطق المنكوبه وهذه احد هذه
العمليات متابعه مباشره معكم عبر شاشه
العربيه
يبدو انهم
انتهوا من لحظه
الصمت على ما يبدو
غسان
لا زالت مستمره
يترقبوا سماع اي صوت من تحت الانقاذ
لاحياء تم جلب كلاب للاستعانه فيهم وايضا
يستخدمون اجهزه حراريه الى جانب هذه
اللحظات الصمت لاستماع لاي اصوات تحت
الانقاض هناك فرق انقاذ عده في هذه
المنطقه
يبدو ان فرق الانقاذ تتحدث وانتهت لحظه
الصمت ما الذي يجري غسان لم افهم
يهتفون باللغه التركيه او يحاولون ايصال
صوتهم للفتاه ان كانت تسمعهم حتى ترد
عليهم